bonjour merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france alors faut-il selon vous déclarer
l'état d'urgence sanitaire en france est
donc donné la possibilité pour le
premier ministre de pouvoir légiférer
par décrets alors qu'il y ait un état
d'urgence site une évidence parce qu'on
voit bien que situé définissant
précisément pandémie même sans précédent
on a donc il faut bien des mesures
d'urgence méheut dans votre dans votre
affirmation il ya quand même quelque
chose qu'il ne faut pas nier c'est qu'
il n'y a pas de confiance aveugle
il peut y avoir une conscience mais ça
doit être une conscience qui doit être
contrôlé et notamment par les mains du
parlementaire c'est pour ça que la
france info me demande un comité
parlementaire justement de suivi pour
pouvoir suivre les décisions qui sont
prises et vérifier qu'elles sont bien
pris dans l'intérêt général
alors justement dans le projet de loi
qui est discuté par l'assemblée
nationale figure notamment pour les
entreprises de rallonger les durées de
travail dans les secteurs encore en
activité ou de limiter et les congés
payés
elle doit t'on craintes pour les acquis
sociaux des salariés effectivement il y
à des mesures qui sont prises qui
consiste à déroger notamment vous
l'avais dit au repos hebdomadaire ou
quand j'ai payé et cetera et cetera
on voit que les mesures qui sont prévues
elles n'ont pas de fin je vous
rappellerai que des mesures d'urgence
nous on a déjà connu en france et elle
ont duré près de deux ans donc est ce
que pendant près de deux ans on va
devoir supporter ces dérogations 1 pour
l'instant la loi telle qu'elle est
écrite elle le prévoit comme ça et nous
ne sommes pas du tout d'accord avec ça
également elle prévoit aussi de définir
des secteurs qui seraient essentiels
mais les secteurs essentiels ce n'est
pas qu'au gouvernement d'aider finir il
faut que les travailleurs définissent
aussi leurs conditions
il faut que les partenaires sociaux
soient également intégrer dans la
discussion est également aussi la
communauté scientifique pour vous voyez
bien que ce n'est pas question de faire
une confiance aveugle de leur laisser
les clés et les pleins pouvoirs il est
question de respecter le jeu
démocratique
c'est à dire de faire partager la
décision avec tout le monde et les
décisions peuvent totalement être prises
avec avec cette contrainte rennais on le
sert le temps n'est pas à la polémique
mais une question reste en suspens
comment la france soumise à kuyt est le
report du second tour des des élections
municipal le gouvernement est il dû
reporter également le premier tour alors
bien évidemment le second tour doit être
reportée c'est une évidence
après bien évidemment ça va poser des
difficultés mais je crois que
l'essentiel là aujourd'hui c'est
l'intérêt général et la protection des
gens de tous ou qu'ils soient et surtout
des plus fragiles qui sont déjà
fragilisés en espérant que cette crise
ne va pas les fragilités davantage et je
regrette notamment que le gouvernement
est toujours très peu de mots pour les
plus fragiles d'entre nous pour ceux qui
sont déjà dehors
pour ceux qui ne peuvent pas opposer
leur droit de retrait aujourd'hui et qui
se retrouvent à travailler dans des
conditions terribles et voire même à
travailler avec la menace du
licenciement quand elle si elle n'a pas
été mise à exécution
on voit qu'aujourd'hui il ya des grosses
difficultés qui sont urgentes et qui
mettent en danger les gens c'est ça la
première urgence
malheureusement là dessus on voit que le
gouvernement dans un discours quand même
assez assez ambivalent ce qu'on appelle
une injonction paradoxale une injonction
contradictoire jeu qu'on dit aux gens
compliqué vous mais en mettant aller
travailler
il faut que les gouvernements soient
claires ce n'est pas une question de
colonies c'est une question de
responsabilité on demande à ce que le
gouvernement soit responsable et claire
dans ses affirmations
merci beaucoup julie garnier d'avoir
répondu à nos questions et je rappelle
que vous êtes oratrice de la france 1ce
mise